we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 david p here's a question
that you i i don't know the implication
from the caller but it's actually a
really good question
which we talked about last week on the
show about what is safe
in the context of the virus take a
listen
hey david this is christian from
louisiana right
i was just wondering it i find it
kind of suspicious that during this
covet pandemic
all these big big box retailers have
been allowed to
you know let almost full capacity
in at all times while small businesses
are reduced to
you know 15 percent in california or 50
in other places
do you think that there's a connection
in this because
all the money that comes to the you know
the senate and the house
and to all these politicians from these
big box retailers
and that they have a vested interest in
keeping their stores open listen i i
don't know about the money piece
but scott atlas recently brought this up
the radiologist that trump had working
for him for a while he also said
why is it that a full capacity big box
store is safe
and a small restaurant at half capacity
is not and you know what i agree with
him
the thing is the conclusion may be
different i don't think the big box
store at full capacity is safe and we
have a report from el paso texas which
actually finds
that a huge amount of the contagion is
happening
in the big box stores now i don't know
exactly what sort of mask wearing
requirements are enforced
uh in el paso texas in big box stores
and certainly
the wearing of masks would reduce the
transmission
but this is a perfectly reasonable
question except for me the answer isn't
open up restaurants at full capacity
which are
very you know smaller lower ceilings
less sophisticated ventilation in many
cases
etc it's i don't think the full capacity
big box stores
make any sense whatsoever so a very
reasonable question which i've been
asking as well
but i think we need to understand which
side is the answer we should be leaning
towards
we have a great bonus show for you today
we will talk about the san francisco
apartment building smoking ban very
interesting news there
we will talk about hunter biden
shockingly we actually have something to
talk about now
related to hunter and we will also talk
about allegations about a friend of the
david pakman show congressman eric
swalwell
all of those stories on today's bonus
show get instant access by signing up
at joinpacman.com